le vietnam est un choix symbolique pour
la tenue du deuxième sommet entre donald
trump et kim jong-un comme la péninsule
coréenne présentement le vietnam a déjà
été coupée en deux pendant plus de vingt
ans à compter de 1954
la corée du nord avait d'ailleurs
soutenu le nord communiste au cours de
la guerre du vietnam qui a fait rage de
1955 à 1975
si le vietnam est toujours communiste
le pays s'est ouvert à l'économie de
marché au cours des dernières décennies
il y a une trentaine d'années c'était
l'un des pays les plus pauvres de la
planète
le vietnam se retrouve maintenant parmi
les 50 économies les plus importantes
mais les états unis croient donc que le
modèle vietnamiens pourrait servir
d'inspiration à kim jong le dernier
dirigeant nord-coréen avoir visité le
vietnam était kim il sung le grand père
de kim jong-un au début des années 60
l'an 2000 bill clinton était le premier
président américain à visiter le vietnam
depuis la fin de la guerre
[Musique]